intelligent
[Musique]
en toute autre matière
l'enfant n'arrivait guère à lire que des
mots comme chat ou rat
des gris clôtures le tramway électrifié
mais quelle grippe peuvent empêcher un
garçon de 13 ans de les franchir il y
avait des écriteaux qui mettaient en
garde le danger d'électrocution des
rails haute tension mais l'enfant ne
pouvait pas les lire puisqu'il ne
pouvait déchiffrer que les mots les plus
simples en conséquence de quoi il est
mort ce qui semble une punition
démesurée pour être un cancre en lecture
non
c'est le premier cas de dyslexie édité
et répertoriés dans living news du 9
août 1926 à Chicago
alors nous sommes le 28 mai 2022 et je
suis très heureuse de vous annoncer que
la dyslexie c'est fini la dyslexie c'est
fini
nous allons passer dans une nouvelle ère
de la dyslexie à l'embilexie
dyslexie lecture 10 orthographies
écriture troubles durable de
l'apprentissage
sans cause neurologiques psychologique
ni déficit intellectuelle
la dyslexie la dysorthographie se
transmettent de façon héréditaire et
génétique
elle touche selon l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé 8 à 12% de la
population mondiale avec plus de 80% de
garçons donc ce chiffre est totalement
daté
selon l'Insee 24% de la population
présente des troubles d'apprentissage
mesdames et messieurs un quart d'entre
nous d'entre vous et 10
nous parlons de dyslexie et de
dysorthographie mais il nous prenons
aussi en charge les 10 calculs les 10
graphiques les dyspraxies certains
dysphasiques les TDA trouvent de la
tension les TDAH trouve de la tension
avec hyperactivité les HPI au potentiel
intellectuel
je ne sais pas pourquoi on parle pas des
quotient émotionnels stratégiques et
relationnelles mais on verra ça plus
tard les hypersensibles bien évidemment
et tous les neurotypes atypiques qui ne
rendent à aucune case alors en fait
est-ce que la norme ne serait-elle pas
hors norme
de même que nous avons réussi à mettre
collectivement fin à la maltraitance
envers les gauchers vers 1968
il est temps d'arrêter de contrarier les
10 à l'école en les obligeant à
apprendre à lire à écrire à écouter à
raisonner à être attentif
à se concentrer avec des outils qui ne
sont adaptés ni à leur qualité
d'apprentissage cognitive exceptionnelle
ni à leur mode divers de traitement des
informations
de quoi ont besoin les 10
ils ont besoin d'être rassurés
pourquoi ont-ils besoin d'être rassuré
alors ils sont hyper empathiques
voyez indice tu sais pas il croise
quelqu'un qui a mal au ventre dans la
rue il a mal au ventre
il voit 36 images par seconde au lieu de
25 il est hyper empathique il veut
sauver le monde entier Gandhi Mère
Teresa des 10 des 10
donc ils ont besoin d'être rassurer
pourquoi parce que ils n'ont aucune
place dans ce monde on ne les comprend
pas on dit qu'ils dysfonctionne alors
vous savez ce qu'on fait et ben on les
soigne
parce qu'il ne fonctionne pas comme 80%
de la population mondiale on les soigne
c'est comme si on continue à soigner les
gauchers
c'est aberrant mesdames et messieurs et
c'est vraiment un problème sociétal et
de santé très très grave
alors ça ça crée un mal-être et une
souffrance
incommensurable des troubles
d'apprentissage qui n'en finit jamais
d'éducations qui peuvent quand même pas
durer 18 ans parce qu'il y a un moment
ça va bien
les cours particuliers et puis les
parents en faire des devoirs parcours du
combattant plus de relations avec leurs
enfants autre que conflictuel
et qu'est-ce qui vivent les 10 on dit
qu'il confondent les sons qui les
inversent
on dit que ils mettent un mot à la place
d'un autre qui confondent la gauche et
la droite qui savent pas se repérer dans
l'espace au fond du n'importe quoi parce
que vous savez
n'est pas dit ce qu'il veut
ah bah oui parce que il y a plein de
disques qui n'ont aucun trouble
d'apprentissage
il y a plein de personnes
qui ont des troubles d'apprentissage qui
ne sont pas 10 il faudrait un peu revoir
les bilans là vous voyez
non mais ça va tout changer ce soir
ah bah non mais je compte sur vous
alors
on est à l'École des Mines ça tombe bien
parce que voilà comment on apprend à
lire à écrire et à faire quoi que ce
soit avec les disques il faut des règles
logique mathématique
physiologique
acoustique
linguistique
neurologique c'est simple
parce que vous comprenez bien que quand
on dit à un petit bonhomme comme ça tu
sais le pays la boule en haut à droite
et puis en fait non quand elle est en
bas à droite elle est bah ça devient
pépicante elle est en haut à gauche ça
devient cupide
tu pourrais pas juste m'apprendre à lire
et écrire
écrit la porte
vous avez vu un haut dans l'alphabet
non mais il y a du suspense là vous
allez comprendre est-ce qu'elle cessé
dit dans l'alphabet
non qu'est-ce qu'on a nous en français
on a une mine d'or dans toutes les
langues il y a des phonèmes et des
graphèmes les phonèmes ce sont les sons
les graphèmes ce sont les façons de les
écrire et ben en français nous on est
super doué on a plus de 34 phonèmes et
on a plus de 610 façons de les écrire
Vald délire messieurs dames
le seul moyen de s'y mettre c'est à
partir de 4 ans en jouant parce que si
on joue au phonèmes et au graphème si on
joue à construire à développer à
conceptualiser ce qu'est en fait le vrai
apprentissage de la lecture et de
l'écriture telle qu'on connaît en
neurosciences aujourd'hui et bien il y
aurait même pu 10 parce que on passerait
direct à l’ambile Lexie en fait voilà
non mais j'ai pas fini
alors je voulais vous dire que les 10
adultes comme les enfants troubles
souffrent particulièrement de ce qu'ils
appellent la maladie de la honte il se
cache esquive qu'on pense créer des
stratégies d'évitement et alors il
compense il compense et puis alors il y
a 80 % des femmes qui sont pas dépister
et arrivent à l'âge adulte va le cerveau
il fait quoi bah il comprend plus
vous savez quand on a mal au dos tout
d'un conducteur mal au dos avant j'avais
pas
et ben là le 10 30 40 ans il fait
j'arrive plus la je suis fatigué là je
suis dépressif et là ce sont les psys et
les médecins qui nous les envoient parce
que le 10 adultes il est pas pris en
charge nulle part dans le monde
mais ça va changer dès aujourd'hui
promis
donc ce sont des caméléons hyper
empathiques ils ne se sentent pas
légitime et voilà comment il le montre
vous voyez comme il est mignon le 10
il est là
il est pas loin quand même la gestation
depuis 1926 elle est un peu longue mais
regardez avant c'était des grilles qu'il
clôture bah là il est en barbelé
voyez c'est quand même
vous pensez qu'il va bien celui-là
on peut on peut se demander
c'est un joli dessin
moi j'ai des parents qui viennent me
voir en me disant
c'est super bien ça ce que vous faites
on comprend rien
on comprend vraiment rien mais il y a
des résultats c'est pour ça qu'on vient
mais quand même l'autre là
mon enfant il est pas passé bien vous
mélangez les degrés dyslexiques et tout
mais mon enfant il est quand même pas
comme ça
après je leur dis oui en même temps
c'est pas un enfant c'est un adulte ah
bon
un adulte qui dessine ça à mes doigts
vraiment mal hein il en institution j'ai
non c'est une institution je vous
présente Tim Burton qui m'a offert ce
cadeau pour vous montrer ce qui était la
dyslexie pour lui et puis des fois il
l'écrit alors quand il écrit c'est très
joli
Juliette 10 ans je la cite
il parut alors à mes yeux une femme dans
la lettre dans la peau n'était que chair
et son non il parut alors à mes yeux il
faut bien que je signe du Liette il
parut alors à mes yeux une femme dont la
peau née que l'être et son
cette femme arracher sa peau en silence
pour former des phrases d'amour
qu'elle offrait à tout le monde
mais à jour cette femme nue plus de peau
pour former des phrases d'amour alors
elle plongea dans un chagrin immense
qu'il a tu as
donc en gros à partir de 8 ou 9 ans le
10 de toute façon il veut mourir
alors le docteur Jean météo neurologue
linguiste d'écrivain poète mon mentor et
mon ami pendant 30 ans disait mais ça
sert à rien de faire copier 25000 fois
les mots au 10 ils ne visualise pas les
lettres et visualise le sens le son et
l'acoustique les spectres
alors
et bien il disait on écrit pas avec la
main on écrit avec l'oreille écrire la
voiture est et vous allez trouver la
couleur ça c'est un code on a souvent
des des couleurs qui vont avec les
voitures
je vais vous dire quand je ferai la
couleur
c'était
rouge ils sont forts
je vais vous poser une question très
importante mesdames et messieurs
pour un petit peu savoir qui est
dyslexique dans la salle dans la salle
qui dit qu'elle était propre
qui dit qu'elle était sale
vous n'êtes pas obligé de le dire
elle était propre
comment c'est possible
il y a des mutants parmi nous ce soir
les équipes de puissance 10 ont
travaillé avec des linguistes du monde
entier je vais vous dire exactement leur
définition de la dyslexie à
l'embylexique
le terme dyslexique portant lui l'idée
d'un dysfonctionnement et d'une anomalie
l'analyse de nombreux corpus de 10 par
des linguistes du monde entier dans
différentes langues à démontré qu'ils
utilisent une langue neurologique
universelle la première langue
neurologique universelle
avec une syntaxe des règles de lecture
ainsi que des fonctions linguistiques
précises
l'apprentissage de la langue officielle
leur demande de devenir bilingue donc de
maîtriser un double lexique celui de
leur langue naturelle et celui de la
langue officielle si on stimule les
caractéristiques de leur langue ils
deviennent alors ambilex ou bilexique et
le préfixe 10 disparaît à jamais
leur production écrite et leur capacité
à apprendre sont amplifiées cohérentes
voire excellente
parlons 10
parlons 10 je cite
effusion de fraîcheur et fusion de
fraîches
le terme dyslexie
urinqueur portant lui l'idée d'un
dysfonctionnement on l'a dit
est une anomalie
[Musique]
alors je m'adresse à vous
clinique imponiatre orthophoniste
psychologue
parents
en segment pourquoi pas
cousin frère sœur
on constate que quand on n'arrive pas à
constater on laisse à l'état de chiffres
riches des cerveaux qui marchent
parfaitement mais surtout surtout et
puis ça il faut le dire plutôt une fois
que deux
on leur laisse porter comme une faute
constante leur mauvaise perforation
scolaire
en les chargeant de tout ce qui va mal
ça abîme la confiance ça casse la joie
de vivre ça fait souffrir sans pouvoir
le dire
le propre du 10 et de désorienter son
auditorium sans le vouloir surtout sans
le vouloir du tout
ils sont l'interrupteur du tibati plus
il veut rentrer dans le chemin droit
dans le chemin et plus il désoriente
l'autre quand même
qu'il soit dyslexique de souche ou
naturalisée
les mots sont consignés d'images en
révérence au sens
aujourd'hui j'ai vu un patient qui a eu
des points de soudure en unité de soins
attentifs
j'ai mal aux plexus scolaire car je dois
faire un exercice dramatique
alors les solutions et bien oui il faut
repérer la dyslexie et il faut que ça
soit gratuit il faut le faire partout
et puis il faut aussi une rééducation
efficace en numérique ou en présentiel
je vais vous résumer
ce que j'en pense
pour moi
une rééducation des troubles 10 doit
être rapide
moins d'un an
beaucoup moins d'un an
efficace ludique attractive durable
sinon c'est pas de la rééducation et
puis il faut aussi arrêter de soigner
des gens qui sont pas malade
alors nous sommes le 28 mai 2022
et la dyslexie c'est fini nous savons
comment la repérer
empêcher l'installation des troubles
les rééduquer s'ils sont déjà installés
et développer les potentialités
c'est donc le début d'une nouvelle ère
qui va changer la vie de milliers de
personnes sur cette terre et pour nous
neurotypique en quête de marginalisation
qui nous accrochons à une société en
pleine transition et si
ce n'était pas une fantastique
opportunité
merci
[Applaudissements]